Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 22. Ausgabe in unserer Serie von Gesprächen, wo es geht rund um die Raumfahrt. Und heute tauchen wir auch mal in ein Themenfeld ein, was so ein bisschen aus der Reihe fällt und sich vor allem viel mit der Zukunft der Raumfahrt auseinandersetzt und wie es sonst auch noch sein könnte. Ich bin dieses Mal nach Holland gefahren, das zweite Mal an den Standort in Nordwijk bei Leiden, genauer dem ASTEC, einem der großen Standorte der ESA. Und im Mittelpunkt des Gesprächs steht eine ganz spezielle Gruppe, die hier ansässig ist, das sogenannte Advanced Concepts Team der ESA. Und als Gesprächspartner dafür begrüße ich Leopold, Leopold Summerer, hallo. Ja, deine Rolle ist genau welche in diesem Team? Hattest du eigentlich einen Titel?
Der Titel ist Head of Advanced Concepts Team, was im täglichen Job bedeutet, dass ich eine Gruppe von Wissenschaftlern koordiniere, die alle ein bisschen intelligenter sind als ich und die alle von ihren Themen wesentlich mehr verstehen als ich, was auch bedeutet, dass es dauernd neue Themen gibt, neue interessante Aufgaben, die die Wissenschaftler in die Gruppe bringen, die sie dann weiterführen. Ich bin der, der eher die großen Linien vorgibt, die richtigen Rahmenbedingungen schafft.
Quasi der Manager, der Koordinator der Gruppe.
Wissenschaftler zu managen ist nicht wirklich einfach. Koordinator ist wahrscheinlich schon zieltreffend.
Das hat wahrscheinlich mit Katzenhütten zu tun, oder? Warum soll das anders sein als im Software-Business? Ja, ich meine, so ganz unwissenschaftlich bist du aber nicht. Was hast du denn für einen Weg genommen, um hier zu landen?
Ich hab Physik studiert mit einem Schwerpunkt auf theoretischer Physik auf der TU Wien. Hab dann meine Doktorarbeit in Nuklearphysik gemacht am Atominstitut der Österreichischen Universitäten, auch in Wien. Bin dann eine Zeit lang in Frankreich gewesen, in Japan. Und relativ kurz nach dem Ende der Doktorarbeit hab ich da bei der ESA angefangen als Wissenschaftler, sogenannt Research Fellow. Research Fellow ist das Postdoc-Programm der ESA. Und so hat sich das weiterentwickelt. Die Gruppe des Advanced Concepts Team ist, ich war quasi der zweite Research Fellow in der Gruppe. Und wir haben am Anfang die Gruppe mehr oder weniger auf einem Blanksheet of Paper, auf einem leeren Blatt Papier konzipiert. Und was wir jetzt sehen, ist mehr oder weniger das Resultat von vielen Iterationen, trial and error, was funktioniert, was nicht funktioniert. Aber im Großen und Ganzen, die Anfangsvorgaben haben sich nicht so stark verändert. Also wir sind immer noch in der gleichen Richtung, wie 2002, als die Gruppe kreiert worden ist, von Franco Ungaro und Andres Galvez damals.
Aber was war denn jetzt sozusagen der Grund und Auslöser dafür, dass diese Gruppe überhaupt ins Leben gerufen wurde? Also es gibt ja hier für alle möglichen Projekte, gibt es die zugehörige Gruppe und da wird halt in der Regel auch immer konkret etwas verfolgt. Das hatten wir jetzt hier auch bei Raumzeit immer wieder. Da muss halt ein Versorgungskapsel zur ISS geflogen werden, etc. Alles hat seine Aufgaben und dafür gibt es das Team, das Advanced Concepts Team in dem Sinne, hat ja nicht so ein konkretes Projekt, was dann einmal fliegt und dann ist es vorbei.
Das ist absolut richtig. Der Grund, warum es die Gruppe einen für sich gibt, ist, dass man im Weltraum und bei Weltraumprojekten muss man schon für jedes Projekt ein gewisses Maß an Risiko in Kauf nehmen, weil Weltraumprojekte einfach risikobehaftet sind aufgrund ihrer Natur und deswegen dauern sie auch relativ lang, um sie vorzubereiten. Einmal, wenn Satelliten im Weltraum sind, kann man nicht mehr viel ändern. Man kann es nicht reparieren. Und sie kosten relativ viel. Deswegen versucht man, als Ingenieur natürlich Safety Margins einzubauen, konservativ zu sein, die Technologien, die man verwendet, vorher ausführlich zu testen, ob eh alles so funktionieren, wie man es sich so vorstellt. Weil an und für sich ist die Aufgabe schon so schwierig und so risikobehaftet, dass man nicht noch zusätzlich Risiko einfügen will mit neuen Technologien, die man unter Umständen nicht unbedingt braucht.
Also wendet man sich im Wesentlichen der gut abgehangenen Technik zu, wo man weiß, das hat sich schon über Jahre bewährt und das Risikopotential ist zumindest überschaubar.
Richtig. Wenn man das allerdings weiter spinnt, kommt man in einen gewissen Konservatismus, in dem man schwer rauskommt. Weil es ist immer schwierig, komplett neue Ansätze in reguläre Technologieprogramme einzubringen.
So nach dem Motto, letztes Mal hat es doch auch funktioniert, lass uns doch das nehmen.
Es gibt nie genug Geld und Ressourcen, um sicher zu gehen, dass die Technologie, die man jetzt wirklich braucht und die man noch ein bisschen weiterentwickelt, noch ein bisschen fähiger, kompetenter machen muss, dafür gibt es nie genug Geld. Und dann zusätzlich zu dem sagen, aber eigentlich sollten wir auch etwas radikal andere Lösungen anschauen. Diese zwei Ansatzpunkte, sustaining innovation und disruptive innovation, sind schwer zu vereinen in der gleichen Einheit. Und was wir machen, ist seeding research for disruptive innovation. Also wie kann man Problemstellungen, die wir haben, die wir kennen, auch komplett anders angehen?
Disruptive innovation, sustaining innovation, könnte ich mir jetzt so von Begriff her erklären, aber es ist ein stehender Fachbegriff. Das heißt, sustaining innovation ist das Althergebrachte?
Es ist nicht so sehr das Althergebrachte. Sustaining innovation ist das, wenn man Market Leader ist und man hat seine Customer Base, die hat ihre Ansprüche und man weiß genau, was sie als nächstes brauchen und darauf hin macht man neue Produkte, die genau der Core Customer Base entsprechen. Das ist normalerweise incremental innovation. Das heißt, Christensen hat diesen Begriff geprägt im Sektor der Festplatten. Wenn man sich den Festplatten-Sektor anschaut, dann sieht man sehr deutlich, dass die, die im Geschäft waren, mit einer gewissen Technologie, diese Technologie immer besser und auch billiger gemacht haben. Aber die, die am Rande waren, die komplett andere Ansätze angenommen haben, zum Beispiel SSDs im Moment, die am Rande nur eine Nische verdienen konnten, die nehmen dann graduell den Marktführer, den Customer weg.
Die sitzen in den Teppich unter den Füßen.
So ähnlich, ja. Und die Aufgabe des Advanced Concepts Team ist ein bisschen zu schauen, was passiert außerhalb von dem, wo wir eh Markt-Leader sind, wenn man das so sagen kann, für eine Agency.
Also Sustaining Innovation ist so ein bisschen so die Evolution und Disruptive ist die Revolution.
Was passiert an den Grenzen, an den Edges, in den Margins, dass unter Umständen interessant werden könnte, dass wir in den Mainstream reinbringen können. Und dazu braucht man andere Ansätze als für Sustaining Innovation, weil es ist viel größeres Risiko behaftet. Man weiß eben nicht, wer die Customer sind, wie sich eine Technologie entwickelt. Man weiß nicht, wie man diese Technologien in neue Produkte, in Satelliten zum Beispiel integrieren könnte. Also da ist wesentlich größeres Risiko behaftet und wesentlich stärker der Research-Ansatz, ein akademischer Ansatz notwendig als für Sustaining Innovation, wo es schon Kompetenz auch in der Industrie gibt, die man weiterführt, auf die man sich verlassen kann.
Verstehe. Das heißt, das Advanced Concepts Team ist quasi einberufen worden, um unabhängig von so Projektzwängen die Ideen einfach mal voranzutragen und darüber nachzudenken, wie könnte man es denn auch machen, dass man einfach auch Zeit und Energie investiert, die natürlich in den anderen Projekten extrem kostbar ist, weil man so zielorientiert arbeiten muss, dass man eben sagt, wir sind jetzt hier unabhängig und wir denken uns jetzt einfach mal den Satelliten, schlüpfen den quasi von innen nach außen und betrachten einfach die Problemfelder, die sich immer ergeben und die bevorzugt konservativ gelöst werden, einfach mal anders.
Ja, so ist es. Und das hat, wenn man davon ausgeht, dann hat das eine ganze Menge Auswirkungen, wie man das macht, mit welchen Personen man das macht, mit welchen Kompetenzen man das macht. Und die Art und Weise, wie das Advanced Concepts Team im Moment funktioniert, reflektiert ein bisschen die Notwendigkeit, dass man zum Beispiel Dinge von verschiedenen Geschichtspunkten anschaut, mit verschiedenen Kompetenzhintergründen. Also wir haben zum Beispiel seit Jahren in der Gruppe einen Biologen, und zwar einen wirklichen Biologen, der nicht ohne Space Background zu uns kommt und der ganz anders an Problemstellungen herangeht, als es ein klassischer Weltraumingenieur oder Weltraumwissenschaftler tun wird. Dann haben wir seit jeher einen theoretischen Physiker in der Gruppe, denn der hat oft mathematische Zugänge zu Problemstellungen, die anders sind als der als der Ingenieur, der unter Umständen an einem etwas fundamentaleren Niveau Dinge betrachtet. Also diese Art und Weise interdisziplinär an Ideen, neue Konzepte oder existierende Probleme heranzugehen, das ist etwas, was meines Erachtens ein Fundamental für diese Disruptive Innovation ist.
Also es hat auch ein bisschen mehr was von einem Forschungszentrum, vielleicht auch mehr universitären Ansatz innerhalb der ESA-Organisation, die eigentlich eben zielorientiert ist. Nicht, dass dort sonst keine Forschung betrieben wird, aber eben unter anderen Zwängen und Zielvorgaben.
Die Gruppe funktioniert ein bisschen wie ein akademisches Institut, das multidisziplinär ist, wo es allerdings mit dem Unterschied, dass es keinen Professor gibt, der die Autorität ist auf einem gewissen Gebiet und dieses Gebiet dann mit seiner Gruppe vorantreibt. Diese wissenschaftliche Autorität haben wir in dem Fall nicht. Das ist sicherlich nicht ich und ist auch nicht mein Chef. Sondern wir verlassen uns da sehr stark auf die Postdocs. Das sind die Research Fellows, die in die Gruppe kommen. Die definieren ihren Researchplan eigenständig. Die kommen schon mit Ideen, was unter Umständen interessant sein könnte für den Weltraum, mit ihren eigenen Vorstellungen, wie sie diese Fragestellungen angehen wollen. Und denen lasse ich dann auch relativ große Freiheit, das so zu machen, wie sie glauben, dass es richtig ist. Weil eben sie viel besser wissen als ich, was funktioniert, was nicht funktioniert. Sie kennen die letzten Ergebnisse in ihren Forschungsfeldern, die manchmal überhaupt nicht mit dem Weltraum zu tun haben. Allerdings kommen die dann mit einer Idee, dass das haben wir dort und dort so und so gemacht. Das wäre doch was, was man auch für eine Weltraumanwendung unter Umständen verwenden kann. Oder das wäre auch etwas, was man so radikal anders machen kann. Meine Aufgabe ist dann ein bisschen dazu zu filtern. Vielleicht ein bisschen die Direktionen vorzugeben, was möglich ist innerhalb der relativ kurzen Zeit, die sie zu uns kommen. Was möglich ist mit unseren Mitteln. Aber abgesehen davon kommen die Ideen selten vom Management, selten von mir. Die Ideen kommen von den Wissenschaftlern, die zu uns kommen für ein Jahr, zwei Jahre, manchmal drei Jahre.
Wie groß ist das Team?
Also wir sind ca. 15 Personen, im Moment sind wir 13, aber das schwankt kontinuierlich, weil die Gruppe aus Temporal Researchers besteht, also aus Wissenschaftlern, die manchmal für ein paar Monate kommen, manchmal für ein Jahr, zwei Jahre, drei Jahre.
Also das ist sozusagen so ein Durchlauferhitzer, so ein Inkubator.
Ich weiß nicht, was wir erhitzen.
Naja, also auf jeden Fall so diesen Ideen-Tank. So stelle ich mir das jetzt zumindest vor. Das sind ja Leute, die eigentlich im wesentlichen primär aus dem universitären Kontext kommen.
Sie kommen alle aus dem universitären Kontext.
Genau, also auch noch stark davon geprägt sind. Und sagen wir mal noch, auch frei denken und nicht belastet von der Realität. Ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass sie dann aber auch schnell auch mal gegen die Wand laufen. Dass man sich halt denkt, naja, das wäre toll, wenn man das so und so macht. Und dann kommt dann irgendwann so diese finstere Realität des Weltalls, die dann eben so ein paar Sachen noch mit einbringt, die man vielleicht so noch nicht bedacht hat. Trotz alledem, ich verstehe das jetzt erst mal so als ein Feld des freien Trial and Errors. Man lässt jetzt auch erst mal einfach der Kreativität freien Lauf und schaut mal, was dabei rauskommt. Weil wenn man nämlich zu früh mit der Fliegenpatsche draufhaut und sagt, naja, das haben wir auch schon mal tausendmal rüber nachgedacht, da brauchst du jetzt gar nicht weiterzudenken, dann verpasst man vielleicht eben diesen einen kleinen, genialen Gedanken, der in diesem Grundansatz vielleicht drin gewesen ist, den man aber nicht gesehen hat, weil Wald, Bäume das alte Problem.
Ja, so in etwa, du hast da schon einen interessanten Aspekt angesprochen. Viele der Ideen, die aus der Gruppe kommen, schaffen es nicht in konkreten Projekten, weil sie einfach nicht so interessant sind, wie sie am Anfang ausschauen und so weiter. Also wir haben natürlich intern einen automatischen Filter, was aber wichtig ist, dass man braucht einfach, wenn man eine gute Idee haben will, braucht man 10, 20 nicht so gute Ideen. Und meine Aufgabe ist es, diese 10, 20 nicht so guten Ideen auch zum Vorschein kommen zu lassen und die zumindest so weit in der Gruppe zu generieren, damit andere vielleicht eine gute Idee basierend auf nicht so guten entwickeln können.
Was sind denn das jetzt für Ideen? Also ich meine, das gesagt, 13, 15 Leute so in etwa, arbeitet dann im Wesentlichen jeder für sich oder bilden sich dann so zwei- oder dreier Teams. Wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Ja, die meisten unserer Projekte haben zwei bis drei Wissenschaftler, die sich zusammentun und sagen, ja, da kann ich das beitragen, da kann ich das beitragen. Und normalerweise ist einer der Haupt, der vielleicht auch der, der die Idee gehabt hat und der die Hauptarbeit leistet. Aber es sind meistens zwei, drei, manchmal auch mehr Leute, die da an einem Konzept arbeiten. Und wir haben dann auch die Möglichkeit, wenn wir zu einem, zu dem Stadium kommen, wo wir sagen, die ursprüngliche Idee haben wir jetzt so weit weiterentwickelt. Und wir haben das mit Kollegen hier innerhalb der ESA cross gecheckt. Und sind jetzt zu dem Schluss gekommen, ja eigentlich, da ist was dran, da könnte man jetzt, da sollten wir ein bisschen tiefer gehen. Und natürlich fehlen uns da oft Kompetenzen. Wir können nicht alle Kompetenzen abdecken. Und dann fragen wir UNIS, und zwar nur UNIS, Universitäre Forschungseinrichtungen, ob sie nicht an dem und dem Gebiet interessiert werden, mit uns gemeinsam für ein paar Monate, normalerweise ist es so ein halbes Jahr, gemeinsam zu forschen. Wir sagen, wir würden gern das und das und das machen. Das können wir, die Kompetenz haben wir. Und diesen Teil würden wir abdecken. Aber wir bräuchten jemanden mit dem und dem Background. Wer ist interessiert da mit uns für eine gewisse Zeit lang gemeinsam zu forschen? Da haben wir ein Programm, das nennen wir Ariadna. Das bildet den Rahmen für diese gemeinsame Forschungsarbeit mit Universitäten von ganz Europa.
Geht das in diese Richtung, dass ihr die Universitäten anspricht? Oder kommen auch teilweise die Ideen von Universitäten, die dann bei euch andocken?
Die meisten Ideen kommen von uns, von den Wissenschaftlern, die zu uns kommen, die mit ihren Ideen schon kommen oft, die dann weiterentwickeln, umentwickeln, in der Diskussion mit Teamkollegen generieren. Und die wir dann publizieren, normalerweise publizieren wir ein, zwei Papers, und dann sagen, ja, eigentlich würden wir da weitergehen, und dann schauen wir, dass die Unis, wo wir wissen, dass gewisse Kompetenzen vorhanden sind, dass die darüber Bescheid wissen, dass aber dann verfolgen wir die normalen Standard-ESA-Regeln, wie man die Universitäten einlädt, Proposal abzugeben und so weiter. Da sind wir in gewisser Maße gebunden, was die ESA machen darf und was die ESA machen kann. Das sind dann Call for Proposals, wo wir beschreiben, was wir machen würden, offen für alle Universitäten, und das sind relativ kurze Proposals, weil wir brauchen nicht, so wie normale ESA-Proposals von Industrie, lange administrative Teile des Proposals. Wir brauchen nur wissen, was der Background ist und wie sie das Problem gerne angehen würden. Dann gibt es da intern einen Standard, das heißt Tender Evaluation Board, und da wird dann entschieden, wer das beste Proposal abgegeben hat. Und wir fangen an, gemeinsam das Problem anzugehen. Das ist das, wo die Idee von uns kommt. Wir haben auch eine andere Schiene, und da kommen die Ideen hauptsächlich von den Unis. Das heißt Call for Ideas, wo wir ein Problem vorgeben. Wir wissen, dass es da keine ideale Lösung noch gibt. Da braucht es noch etliche Jahre wissenschaftlichen Fortschritts, um den Nebel ein bisschen zu lichten, was da optimal ist. Da fragen wir Unis, das ist die Problemstellung. Welche Ideen habt ihr, damit man da einen Schritt weiterkommt und vielleicht den Nebel ein bisschen lichtet? Das sind dann Ariadna Call for Ideas. Auf Deutsch würde man dann sagen... Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das auf Österreichisch sagt. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie man das auf Deutsch sagt.
Hilfe uns fällt nichts ein.
Meistens haben wir unsere eigenen Ideen, aber wir wissen ganz genau, dass das nicht der weise letzte Schluss ist. Zum Beispiel vor ein paar Jahren Apophis. Apophis ist einer der nearest objects, der relativ nahe an die Erde kommt.
Also ein Asteroid?
Asteroiden, ja. Dass es in der Verlangenheit Asteroiden-Einschläge gegeben hat. Es ist wahrscheinlich, dass es sie auch in der Zukunft wieder geben wird. Was könnte man machen, um Asteroiden abzulenken? Und da gibt es eine ganze Menge von Ideen, was man da machen kann. Aber jeder weiß, dass es da noch viel Raum für wissenschaftliche Kreativität gibt, was man da machen kann. Und da haben wir Unis gefragt, was würdet ihr vorschlagen, was noch nicht beschrieben ist in der Literatur, was noch nicht vorgeschlagen wird. Wir fragen uns, stellt ihr neue Vorschläge in den Raum? Und dann haben wir drei dieser Vorschläge ein bisschen weiter gespunnet mit ihnen. Und meistens nachher finden Universitäten andere Fundingsources, andere Projekte, wo sie diese Ideen dann weiter entwickeln können. Sobald wir ein Thema behandelt haben, und andere greifen uns auf, machen wir nichts mehr damit. Wir wollen den Initialfunk geben, die ersten paar Schritte schauen, ob das wirklich interessant ist. Dann publizieren wir das, so weit wir können, versuchen, das möglichst vielen Leuten zu erklären. Wir sind nicht diejenigen, die entscheiden, ob das wirklich interessant ist oder nicht. Das müssen andere sein.
Genau, es geht ja um Konzepte. Es steht ja auch im Namen, Konzepte zu erarbeiten und die dann in den Raum zu stellen. Das ist ja dann etwas, worauf andere Projektgruppen dann darauf zugreifen können, in dem Moment, wo sie ihre eigenen Problemstellungen haben, dass sie sagen, aha, hier guck mal, Concepts Team hat schon mal, vielleicht nicht so genau, aber Pi mal Daumen in die gleiche Richtung überlegt. Und das ist das, was dabei rausgekommen ist. Vielleicht kann das ja bei uns in irgendeiner Form eine Auswirkung haben oder vielleicht auch ein Lösungsansatz sein. Kurzer Einwurf, wo Apophis und dieses spezielle Asteroidenproblem, also wie schützen wir die Erde vor einem möglichen Asteroideneinschlag aufkam, das wurde hier auch schon mal theoretisch durchgekaut bei Raumzeit. Und zwar in Ausgabe Nr. 9, Asteroiden und Kometen, sprich mit Ellen Harris vom DLR in Berlin, Institut für Planetenforschung. Da kam das auch zur Sprache. Vielleicht sollten wir mal ein bisschen konkreter werden. Mich würde natürlich jetzt mal interessieren, was sind es nun für Problemstellungen, die jetzt aufgekommen sind. Die Gruppe gibt es seit 2002, also seit über acht Jahren. Da dürfte ja schon die eine oder andere Idee durchmarschiert sein. Zunächst einmal, du hast ja gesagt, es kommt sozusagen von den Leuten, die ins Team reinkommen. Vielleicht kommen sie auch schon mit dieser Idee in das Team rein. Was sind das jetzt für Ideen? Was sind das für Problemstellungen, die da bearbeitet werden? Hast du vielleicht mal ein paar Beispiele, an denen man ganz gut sehen kann, was für Themen das sich überhaupt erstreckt und wie das dann angegangen wird?
Ein sehr anschauliches Beispiel, das kommt gerade aus dem Urlaub. Und in Österreich hat es dieses Jahr viele Bienen und Wespen gegeben. Und ein anschauliches Beispiel, das von dem Thema der Bionik kommt, ist, die einfachsten fliegenden Insekten haben eine unglaubliche Fähigkeit, Precision Landing zu machen. Und zwar können die auf sich bewegende Objekte landen, manchmal unglaublich treffsicher, sehr akrobatische Figuren fliegen in komplizierten Umgebungen. Und vor allem den Landeneffekt wollten wir uns ein bisschen genauer anschauen. Und zwar, wenn man sich eine Biene, oder ein einfacher Mücke, glaube ich heißt das auf Deutsch, bei uns heißt das Gelsen in Österreich, anschaut, dann haben die quasi kein Hirn. Also das Hirn ist im Zehntel von Milligrammbereich. Und trotzdem schaffen die das, unglaublich sicher zu landen, auf den unterschiedlichsten Oberflächen, in den unterschiedlichsten Windumgebungen. Und wir haben immer noch Probleme. Entry, Descend und Landing in unknown territory.
Also zum Beispiel jetzt hier das geplante Rosetta-Experiment, den Länder auf den Kometen niederzulassen.
Es ist etwas, was relativ kompliziert ist, relativ schwierig. Auch Mars-Landing, etliche Proben, die in den Mars eingetaucht sind, sind verloren gegangen in der Phase Entry, Descend und Landing.
Die, die gelandet sind, brauchten dann dicke Ballone runterrum, um erst mal hinzufallen, anstatt einfach nur zu landen, wie das jede Mücke kann.
Und da stellt sich die Frage, wie machen die das genau? Und wir haben da eine super Gruppe gefunden in Marseille, die sich genau mit der Fragestellung von einer biologischen Seite beschäftigt. Wie funktioniert das neuronale System von diesen Insekten, dass sie so schnell reagieren können auf Umgebungsänderungen während des Landens und immer treffsicher genau landen, ohne sich jetzt der Beinen zu brechen.
Man sieht sie selten stolpern, oder?
Und es stellt sich aus, dass Biologen da schon sehr weit fortgeschritten sind in dem Verständnis, was jetzt in dem Bienenauge vor sich geht. Wie die Biene ihre Umgebung processt und daraus schlüsset sieht, wie hoch sie noch über dem Landepunkt ist. Und das ist faszinierend, weil es quasi ohne Computation-Power funktioniert. Das sind analoge Circuits, die, was sich die anschauen, sind Änderungen im, Kontraständerungen in einem gewissen Winkel ihrer Augen. Und wenn sie diesen Winkel und die Änderung konstant halten, was man Optikflow nennt, dann können sie quasi, solange es eine Kontraständerung gibt, auf allen Flächen landen. Und wir haben dann eine kleine, mit der gleichen Gruppe in Marseille und in Zürich, versucht, das in einen kleinen Roboter einzubauen. Das sind eigentlich nur ganz simple Electronic Circuits. Und so Roboter können mit einem sehr einfachen Auge Soft Landing and Take Off machen. Das kostet nichts in Processing Power, das kostet quasi nichts in Hardware, das kostet quasi nichts an Gewicht, weil es extrem leicht ist. Und das ist etwas, das wir...
Was sind das jetzt für Fluggeräte?
Das ist nur so ein Modellroboter, ein Modellhelikopter, den wir da verwendet haben. Der eine kleine Kamera hat. Die Kamera schaut sich nur an, wie schnell da die Kontraste...
Das Bild läuft vorbei, dieser optische Fluss, das heißt, man blickt quasi so abstrakt auf das, was unter einem ist. Und je nachdem, wie sich die Winkel ändern und die Pixel da zusammenfließen, weiß man, ich bin so oder so gekippt und so weit entfernt oder so nah.
Und das funktioniert relativ gut. Und wir sind jetzt dabei, dass unseren Kollegen, die Guidance Navigation Control hier professionell machen, also wie wir es traditionell machen im Weltraum, daran sind doch interessiert. Und unter Umständen könnte das ein Backup-System sein. Also wenn unser Hauptsystem, wir wollen zum Beispiel die Biene weiß nicht, wie hoch sie absolut ist, dass sie jetzt so viele Zentimeter über den Boden ist. Die Biene braucht das auch nicht unbedingt wissen.
Weil sie merkt eh schon, wenn sie dann da ist.
Ja, sie braucht nur wissen, dass sie da sicher landen kann. Aber für die Biene ist es nicht wichtig, dass sie jetzt weiß, sie ist zwei Zentimeter über den Boden. Sie ist...
Abgesehen jetzt von der Geschwindigkeit, ich meine, man sollte da nicht irgendwie den Speed drauf haben, dass man dann zerschellt.
Was die Biene weiß, ist die Ratio zwischen Distanz und Speed. Und wenn sie das konstant hält, dann kann sie Softlining machen.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo sich der Abstand verringert, verringert sich auch automatisch die Geschwindigkeit. Das ist quasi fest verdrahtet.
Genau, das ist fest verdrahtet. So braucht sie nicht genau wissen, wie schnell sie ist. Sie braucht auch nicht genau wissen, wie hoch sie ist.
Sie weiß nur, dass es in einem richtigen Verhältnis stehen muss.
Genau, und unter Umständen könnte man sowas als Backup-System für Entry, Designing, Landing-System machen.
Das heißt, ich bin jetzt nicht mehr ferngesteuert, dann lande ich da einfach selber, wenn es um was selber geht.
Und gerade für Entry, Designing, Landing, das sind normalerweise sehr kritische Momente in einer Mission, weil das kann man nicht fairensteuern, das sind zu weit weg. Da würde die Datenübertragung schon zu lange dauern. Man kann da nicht von der Erde reagieren, wenn da neue Gegebenheiten jetzt da sich auftun. Sondern da muss der Spacecraft autonom entscheiden, ob es jetzt eher weiter rechts, eher weiter links landet, aufgrund der geografischen Gegebenheiten auf dem Mars, auf dem Mond oder wo immer man landen will.
Also autonome Steuerung, denke ich, ist überhaupt ein großes Thema in der Raumfahrt. Weil du schon angedeutet hast, es ist halt weit weg. Funkkommunikation dauert lange. Entweder muss man das in so langsamen Schritten machen, dass man bestimmte Experimente so nicht durchführen könnte, weil die vielleicht einfach einen schnellen Durchflug, schnell mal landen und gleich wieder weg. Weil wenn ich da zu lange bleibe, gehe ich kaputt, warum auch immer. Strahlung, Pipapo, Sonneneinstrahlung, kann ja alle möglichen Gründe haben. Und das ließe sich dann einfach durch Fernsteuerung nicht machen, sodass eben dann die Fragestellung aufkommt, könnte man eben das System autonom machen, sodass dieses Experiment überhaupt durchgeführt werden kann.
Man muss eigentlich Designing-Landing in den meisten Fällen mit einer gewissen Autonomie ausstatten, weil anders geht's gar nicht. Das zum Beispiel Max oder am Hund zu landen, da kann man nicht warten, bis jetzt das Signal von der Erde kommt. Jetzt warte mal, wir überlegen uns das, jetzt gehe ich rechts, gehe ich links. So funktioniert das nicht. Das läuft innerhalb von Minuten ab.
Als ob man der fallenden Katze sagen wollen würde, wie sie sich zu drehen hat, damit sie auf ihren Beinen landet.
Genau, die fallende Katze. Muss das schon selbst entscheiden.
Wie weit wird dann diese Idee durchgedacht, bis das sozusagen ein fertiges Konzept ist?
Das erste war natürlich anzuschauen, ob man überhaupt genug versteht vom biologischen Prozess, sodass man das abstrahieren kann und in ein technologisches Konzept einbinden kann. Das war der erste Schritt. Das hätte schon ausgehen können und sagen, eigentlich weiß man da nicht genug, um das zu abstrahieren. Aber das war der erste Schritt. Der zweite Schritt ist, wenn man das abstrahieren kann, kann man das mit jetzigen technologischen Möglichkeiten überhaupt realisieren. Da ist es gut, wenn man Kompetenzen zusätzlich zu den Biologen einbringt. Da geht es darum, wie man das in einen Prozessor implementiert, welche Art von Sensoren kann man da verwenden, was sind deren Parameter und so weiter. Das ist quasi der letzte Schritt, den wir machen. Unter Umständen in dem Fall haben wir mit den Unis ein Proof of Concept gemacht, wo die in Marseille haben das in einem Roboter implementiert und haben gesagt, ihr könnt Soft-Laning und Take-Off machen.
Funktioniert einfach.
Aber der nächste Schritt ist eigentlich schon nicht mehr von uns. Weil um das dann in einer Weise zu machen, die ESA Programme interessieren kann, dazu fehlt uns die genaue Kompetenz. Das muss dann das technische Direktorat hier übernehmen. Und die wissen dann, in welche Art und Weise man die Idee und das Konzept so weiterentwickelt, dass es interessant sein kann für die Integration in wirkliche Missionen.
Weil dann natürlich ganz andere Bedingungen kommen.
Strahlenresistenz, Temperaturen. Auch die Integration in wirkliche Spacecraft. Man kann zwar wissen, wie das jetzt in der Biene abläuft, aber ein Landing-Spacecraft hat ganz andere Ansprüche. Da gibt es Dinge, wie man die Interfaces baut. Das sind dann Kompetenzen, die das reguläre, technische Direktorat in der ESA hat, um das zu entscheiden. Das sind dann nicht mehr wir. Passfinder.
Aber Biologie ist schon mal so ein Schwerpunkt. Ich meine, Bionik ist als Stichwort schon genannt. Also im Wesentlichen die Funktionalitäten der Natur nachzuvollziehen, also vor allem so die Mechanik. Gibt es da noch andere Berührungspunkte mit biologischer Forschung?
Ja, wir haben auch relativ exotische Sachen angeschaut, wie zum Beispiel verkürzten Wurzeln. Das ist vielleicht etwas, was nicht so naheliegend ist, aber wenn man sich Wurzeln ansieht, wie sie Ressourcen in verschiedenen Böden aufnehmen und wie sich Wurzeln wann entscheiden, da jetzt Ableger zu machen und wann sie entscheiden, welche Ableger weiterentwickelt werden sollen und welche nicht, dann ist das in zweierlei Hinsicht interessant. Wir haben uns beide Aspekte bis jetzt angeschaut. Das erste ist, Wurzeln können in sehr unterschiedlichen Böden sich fortbewegen, wenn man das so ausdrücken kann. Sie können Wurzeln schlagen in ganz unterschiedlichen Böden. Sehr langsam, aber sehr sicher. Und wie die das machen, ist anderen für sich schon interessant. Im Moment, wenn wir Samples von Böden nehmen wollen, dann haben wir eigentlich einen normalen Bohreransatz. Wurzeln haben ganz andere Möglichkeiten, da zu bohren in Böden. Und der zweite interessante Ansatz von Wurzeln, der noch weniger auf der Hand liegt, ist, wenn man sich eine Wurzel anschaut, nachdem sie sich entwickelt hat, dann sieht man alle Entscheidungsprozesse an der Wurzel, die Historie der Wurzel.
Das sagt eine Menge über die Struktur des Bodens aus.
Das sagt eine Menge über die Struktur des Bodens aus. Und das ist der Aspekt, die Artificial Intelligence war daran interessiert. Du wirst vielleicht schon gehört haben über die interessanten Forschungen über Böder-Flocks und Fischflocks, Fischschwärme.
Also Schwarmintelligenz.
Schwarmintelligenz, genau. Und da ist es immer schwierig, die Daten zu finden, wann jetzt welche Entscheidung von dem Schwarm getroffen wird. Da braucht man High-Speed-Recording und so weiter. Die Wurzel trifft ähnliche, also wenn man das abstrahiert, für jemanden, der Artificial Intelligence interessiert ist, trifft ähnliche Entscheidungen, zwar an verschiedensten Punkten, zu gewissen, zu verschiedenen Zeitpunkten. Allerdings hat man die gesamte Historie, sobald man die Wurzel rausnimmt. Und da gibt es aber interessante Wurzelforscher in Portugal, mit denen wir da zusammengearbeitet haben. Weil uns natürlich die eigentliche Kompetenz über die, wie Wurzeln wann entscheiden, sich zu spalten, welcher Wurzelstamm glaube ich heißt, dass jetzt stärker weniger stark entwickelt wird und so weiter. Wie die Entscheidung getroffen wird, ob das eine zentrale oder komplett dezentrale Entscheidung ist.
Also ob es auch Kommunikation gibt.
Wie die Kommunikation ist, wie die Kommunikation mit dem Environment ist. Das ist interessant für Artificial Intelligence-Forscher, weil die müssen oft Unknown Solution Spaces exploren. Das heißt, du weißt, es gibt verschiedenste Lösungen für dein Problem, aber der Lösungsraum ist so groß, dass du ihn nicht komplett abdecken kannst. Das heißt, du musst Entscheidungen treffen, basierend auf was du schon weißt von gewissen Gebieten.
Das heißt, man will diesen Lösungsraum durchdringen, so wie ein Wurzelgeflecht den Boden durchdringt und mit so einer dezentralen Analyse voranschreiten und dann hat man auch gleich diesen Baum der Entscheidung und kann sehen, hier ist es tiefer, da kam mehr Wasser, da kamen mehr diese Nährstoffe.
Ja, genau, das sind so Ansätze, die glaube ich schon deutlich machen, dass das sehr schwierig ist in einem traditionellen Technologie-Entwicklungsprogramm für den Weltraum. Die kann man schwer unterbringen, weil das sind Sachen, die sehr unsicher sind, wo man nicht genau weiß, was rauskommt mit Partnern, die unter Umständen mit dem Weltraum vorher überhaupt nichts zu tun gehabt haben.
Vor allem ist es nicht nur eine technische Lösung für ein konkretes Problem, sondern es geht auch um Lösungen zu finden.
Richtig.
Methodiken zu entwickeln oder Vorlagen für Methodiken zu entwickeln, die man dann zum Einsatz bringen kann, um ganz was anderes zu lösen, was erst mal damit gar nichts zu tun hat.
Also das Bionik ist ja nicht so sehr die Natur nachzuahmen, sondern es ist eher zu sehen, welche Lösungen hat die Natur gefunden für ganz spezifische Probleme. Und dann sind die, wie kann man ähnliche Lösungsansätze auch für unsere Probleme finden. Und das ist ein sehr, sehr reiches Forschungsgebiet, wo es immer wieder Überraschungen gibt.
Da braucht man nur mit der Lupe in den Wald zu gehen und schon hat man wieder einen neuen Ansatz. Spannend. Aber ich denke, gibt die Biologie bei euch noch mehr her? Es ist ja ein spannendes Feld, so Materialforschung etc. ist ja sicherlich da auch nicht ganz uninteressant. Spielt das eine Rolle oder hat das schon mal eine Rolle gespielt?
Ja, zum Beispiel haben wir uns angeschaut, die Festigkeitsanalysen von Pflanzenstängel. Pflanzenstängel haben gewisse Aufgaben in der Natur. Eine der Aufgaben ist Festigkeit. Die Natur hat verschiedenste Lösungen gefunden, um Pflanzenstängel resistent zu machen gegen Knicken. Im Weltraum haben wir immer wieder die Notwendigkeit, gewisse Sensoren weit weg von dem Hauptspacecraft zu bringen, um undisturbedeutigte Measurements zu machen. Und da hat die Natur Lösungen parat, die wir unter Stunden jetzt noch nicht technisch realisieren können, weil einfach die Strukturen zu kompliziert zu bauen wären. Bambus ist eine Art und Weise, aber einfach Gräser haben ganz interessante Ansätze, wie man sie flexibel macht und doch knickbeständig. Das ist ein Beispiel, das wir uns angeschaut haben. Nur für ein paar Monate mit einem Stagier. Vor ein paar Jahren. Aber das wäre ein Beispiel von der Materialwissenschaft.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, es ist ein bisschen schwierig zu erahnen, womit ihr euch noch alles so beschäftigt habt. Das sind ja jetzt schon sehr unterschiedliche Sachen. Auf der einen Seite ist es eine Vorlage für, wie finde ich überhaupt eine Lösung? Dann ist es so, wie baue ich etwas? Jetzt geht es auch ins Bauen, ins Konstruieren rein. Das ist ja schon ein relativ weites Feld, das jetzt nur aus der Biologie herauskommt.
Wir können die anderen Hauptwissenschaftsfelder, die wir bis jetzt haben, vielleicht kurz erwähnen. Dann auf das eine oder andere Projekt ein bisschen näher eingehen. Zum Beispiel beschäftigen wir seit einer gewissen Zeit mit Advanced Propulsion Systems. Das heißt, Antriebssysteme, die etwas unkonventionell sind. Am Anfang war das hauptsächlich Idea-Debunking. Also schauen, warum gewisse Ideen, die immer wieder vorgebracht waren, eigentlich nicht funktionieren können. Dazu war zum Beispiel der theoretische Physiker in der Gruppe unglaublich wichtig, weil manchmal kommen da Ideen, die sehr kompliziert ausschauen, sehr kompliziert sind. Aber man muss da wirklich ins Detail gehen und zu sehen, welche Details da dem Standardmodell der Physik widersprechen.
Verstehe, das ist sozusagen einfach ausgerechnet, dass es nicht gehen kann.
Ja, genau.
Was ist da zum Beispiel abgeprallt an ihm?
Ja, ich will an niemanden jetzt...
Es gibt ja sicherlich Ideen, die generell immer wieder vorangetragen wurden, die man dann ausbieten kann.
Das sind wirklich vielfache Enthusiasten, die mit ganz komplizierten physikalischen Ideen kommen, wie man da jetzt Energie generieren kann aus dem Vakuum. Das sind in gewisser Weise... Also, Vakuum-Energie ist eines der Dinge. Man kann aus dem Vakuum temporär Energie gewinnen, aber kann man da auch was machen, in welchen Timescales und so weiter. Da muss man dann schon wirklich ins Detail gehen und sagen, warum gewisse Sachen nicht funktionieren und warum sie unter Umständen funktionieren können. Manche Konzepte kommen direkt aus Star Trek. Da muss man halt auch schauen, was unter Umständen vielleicht theoretisch irgendwann möglich ist, aber es ist momentan noch nicht relevant, sich das als Space Agency genauer anzuschauen, weil das noch science fiction ist.
Ja, erinnert mich so ein bisschen an die Zeit, als diese ganzen Flugapparate gebaut wurden und man so über alle möglichen Aspekte daher kam. Was muss man jetzt machen, um den Vogel nachzumachen? Muss man im Wesentlichen flattern oder muss man schweben? Was ist es denn jetzt eigentlich? Und ist ja klar, dass man da auch alle Wege erstmal verfolgen muss und sich danach vielleicht auch mal eine blutige Nase holt.
So ist es.
Es ist schön, wenn einem einer ausrechnen kann, dass man sich eine blutige Nase holen würde. Das ist ja zuträglich der eigenen Gesundheit.
Dann gibt es da auch, was sehr interessant war in dem Bereich Probalgen, zu schauen, wie die Fusionsenergieforscher, die sich auch mit hochenergetischen Plasmas beschäftigen müssen, wie die ihre Plasmasströme modellieren, wie sie sie generieren. Und da sind wir gemeinsam mit einer italienischen Uni in Padua einen Helikon-Trust konzipiert, der sehr interessant ist. Von meiner Seite, von meiner Warte aus, deswegen auch, weil die Gruppe vorher nichts mit Weltraum zu tun gehabt hat. Und wir haben mit denen eine kleine Ariadna-Studie gemacht. Ich glaube sieben, acht Monate hat die damals gedauert. Und daraufhin haben sie established Space Propulsion Companies in Europa kontaktiert. Und ich sag, schaut euch das mal genauer an. Sollten wir da nicht die Europäische Union mit ihrem Framework-Programm kontaktieren. Und die haben da eine Gruppe zusammengestellt mit Franzosen, Italienern, Deutschen. Und haben aufgrund der Idee, die im Rahmen eines 25.000 Euro kleinen Forschungsprojektes von uns haben die 3,5 Millionen Euro von der Europäischen Union bekommen für ein mehrjähriges Forschungsprogramm, wo es wirklich darum geht, Laboratory Prototypes zu machen. Das funktioniert wunderbar. Das ist eine Gruppe, die im Weltraum vorher sehr wenig.
Was machen die jetzt mit dem Plasma?
Das ist so ein Helikontrastor. Da wird Plasma generiert mit Microwaves.
Also so ionisiertes Gas.
Das leuchtet schön. Das haben wir auch da schon getestet. Das ist ein Konzept, das aus der Fusionsforschung ursprünglich kommt.
Das soll dem Antrieb dienen?
Das soll dem Antrieb dienen. Elektrische Antriebe, da geht es darum, Teilchen möglichst effizient zu beschleunigen. Das heißt, wie transferiert man genügend Energie und Impuls an Gasteilchen, die man dann auf einer Seite schnell rausschiebt.
Ja, so wie man es jetzt mit der normalen Verbrennung auch schon macht in Raketentriebwerden.
Genau.
Da wird dann einfach viel verbrannt, aber Verbrennung ist halt nicht besonders effizient, weil nicht wahr, das haut dann viel raus.
Und da gibt es etliche Konzepte für Elektropropulsion, etablierte Konzepte seit den 70er Jahren, Ion Grids, das sind so graded ion thrusters, wo man, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das auf Deutsch sagt, die fliegen in jetzigen Spacecrafts. Diese Art der Propulsion wäre dann wesentlich effizienter, wenn es funktioniert, also wir sind da wirklich noch in einem Forschungsstadium.
Inwiefern unterscheidet sich denn das jetzt von diesem Ionenantrieb?
Das wäre ein Ionenantrieb.
Aber das gibt es doch schon. Ich meine, ESA ist ja mit dem Smart 1 zum Mond geflogen, das meinst du jetzt, ja?
Und das wäre eine komplett andere Art und Weise, wie man über die generiert.
Aber ich meine, was muss denn da jetzt noch so advanced dran geforscht werden, wenn man schon weiß, dass es funktioniert?
Wir forschen nicht an dem regulären Ionenantrieb. Der funktioniert hervorragend.
Aber inwiefern unterscheidet sich das jetzt von dem, was es schon gibt?
Ein Hauptunterschied ist, dass man keinen Grid mehr braucht. Und diese Ion-Grid-Engines, da werden die Ionen durch ein Gitter beschleunigt. Und in dem Prozess, wo sie durch das Gitter durchgehen, korrodieren sie dieses Gitter. Und nach einiger Zeit wird die Effizienz geringer, weil das Gitter eben korrodiert. Verstehe, Verschleiß. Verschleiß, ja. Und wenn man da Konzepte hat, die kein Gitter brauchen, die unter Umständen die Energieübertragung an die Ionen wesentlich effizienter gestalten können, dann ist das interessant. Verstehe. Das heißt nicht, die goldene Regel der Gruppe ist, sobald jemand anderer innerhalb der ESA oder außerhalb der ESA in Europa etwas macht, dann ist das nicht mehr advanced genug für uns, dann machen wir was anderes. Das stimmt natürlich nicht für große Gebiete. Nicht weil jemand Electric Propulsion macht, schauen wir uns Electric Propulsion überhaupt nicht an. Sondern wir schauen uns Dinge an, die komplett anders funktionieren würden. Aber natürlich in dem gleichen Themenbereich sind Propulsion ist interessant.
Propulsion ist auch eines der großen Themen innerhalb des Advanced Concepts Team.
Propulsion ist ein interessantes Thema. Wir schauen uns jetzt zum Beispiel einen deutschen Research Fellow von Stuttgart an. Wir sind noch nicht sehr weit, aber es schaut interessant aus, der will sich Fusion Propulsion anschauen. Da gibt es interessante theoretische Ansätze, wie sowas funktionieren könnte.
Also so eine kleine Sonne sozusagen.
Ja, es funktioniert anders. Das ist Inertial Electric Confinement Fusion. Das ist die Richtung, die er sich anschaut. Propulsion ist ein interessantes Thema. Da gibt es viele Ideen, wie man Dinge...
Gibt es da auch viel Interesse daran? Ich frage mich auch immer wieder, wie wird das innerhalb der ESA oder auch von anderen Raumfahrtagenturen aufgenommen und angenommen? Ob es jetzt direkt so eins zu eins umgesetzt wird? Das ist ja jetzt nochmal eine andere Frage, ob generell auch von innen heraus ein wissenschaftliches Interesse und ein Austausch auch besteht. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es gerade bei den Antrieben, wo es ja schnell sehr handfest wird, während die Idee mit den Wurzeln ja eher ein Gedankenmodell ist, gibt es da sehr viel mehr Kommunikation?
Die Art und Weise, wie wir das innerhalb der ESA angehen, ist, bevor wir... Also nachdem wir intern das Gebiet angeschaut haben, ob das nicht wirklich ein Schwachsinn ist oder ob wir nicht irgendwas fundamental vergessen haben oder so weiter. Bevor wir rausgehen und den Uni sagen, das wollen wir gern genauer anschauen, schauen wir hier den Fragen der Experten hier in den verschiedenen Departments. Also sobald wir was am ProParschen machen, gehen wir zu den Kollegen hier in ProParschen und sagen, das würden wir gern anschauen, habt ihr schon davon gehört. Ist das interessant, ist das Waste of Time? Und da kriegt man interessantes Feedback. Da kommt manchmal, ich hab schon mal gehört, ich weiß, dass das und das und das hat mal was probiert, was so ähnlich war oder so. Oder manchmal sagen die, das wird nicht funktionieren aufgrund von dem und dem. Und wenn wir das noch nicht vorher betrachtet haben, dann sagen wir, okay, guter Punkt.
Das ist der internen Reality-Check für die Konzepte?
Ja, wir machen den internen Reality-Check. Aber meistens ist es so, dass sie sagen, wenn das funktioniert, das wär interessant. Und je nachdem, wie viel Zeit die Kollegen dann haben, dass sie die Projekte mit begleiten, entweder begleiten sie die gemeinsam mit uns. Vielfach ist es, wenn es zu weit ist, schauen wir uns das genauer an und schauen, was da rausgekommen ist. Und wenn das dann wirklich so interessant ist, dann nehmen die das in ihrer eigenen Technology Development Roadmaps auf und laufen dann damit. Da gibt es etliche Beispiele von optischen Metamaterialien zum Beispiel, bis zu in Robotics. Die Guidance Navigation Controller habe ich schon verwendet. Etliche Dinge bezüglich mathematischen Modellen für Global Optimization. Global Optimization ist, wir verwenden das hauptsächlich für Bahnberechnungen. Wenn man gewisse Asteroiden zum Beispiel besuchen will, dann gibt es höchstwahrscheinlich einen optimalen Weg dorthin zu bekommen. Aber es ist nicht analytisch einfach zu sagen, das ist der optimale Weg.
Darum fliegen, sich dann noch mal Schwung holen etc.
Genau, da gibt es eine ganze Menge von Parametern. Angefangen von wann man startet, in welche Richtung, welche Planeten man vorbeifliegt, wie lang die Gesamtdauer der Mission ist usw. Und da hat man einen Lösungsraum, der sehr multidimensional ist.
Wenn nicht sogar unendlich.
Unendlich ist nur die Dummheit der Menschheit. Und da hat ein Kollege von mir, Dario Izzo, eine ganz interessante Feststellung gemacht nach etlichen Konferenzen bezüglich Global Optimization for Trajectories. Dass Forscher grundsätzlich eine neue Methode präsentieren, die dann mit existierenden Methoden vergleichen. Aber die Vergleiche sind natürlich immer etwas, die hitten immer etwas, weil sie unter anderem Rahmenbedingungen stattgefunden haben und so weiter. Und deswegen ist es sehr schwierig zu sagen, das ist jetzt eine bessere Methode als diese Methode für gewisse Probleme. Und er hat gesagt, warum machen wir nicht einen Wettbewerb, wo wir vorgeben, was das Problem ist, was die Problemstellung ist und was wir optimieren wollen. Das war zum Beispiel eine Impact-Mission an einen gewissen Asteroiden.
Also was reinschießen und danach den aufgewirbelten Staub analysieren.
Nein, nein, nein, das war wirklich eine theoretische Analyse, wie kann man maximal Impuls einem Asteroiden übermitteln.
Um seine Bahn zu ändern zum Beispiel. Okay, wieder das Erdrettungsmodell.
Erdrettungsmodell zum Beispiel. Und er hat gesagt, das ist die Bahn des Asteroiden. Es gibt ein Launch-Window von Datum X bis Datum X, gewisse andere Parameter wie z.B. Initial Delta, gewisse Initialgeschwindigkeit. Und den Rest findet die Bahn, die den meisten Impuls an den Asteroiden weitergibt. Und alle haben einen Monat Zeit und die Lösung muss in einem gewissen Format submitted werden, sodass sie vergleichbar sind. Und das war von Anfang an ein Riesenerfolg, weil Teams von Amerika, Russland, China, Japan und so haben gesagt, das ist interessant, weil da können wir unsere Methoden vergleichen mit anderen Methoden unter gleichen Rahmenbedingungen.
Ist das jetzt vor allem was für Mathematiker oder Missionsplaner im weiteren Sinne?
Ja, genau. Und zwar eine der Gründe, warum wir das machen wollten, die Mathematiker, die mit dem Weltraum an und für sich wenig zu tun haben, in den Weltraum locken und sagen, wir geben euch alle Tools, wie man das im Weltraum macht. Ihr schaut, was gibt es für mathematische Ansätze, um das besser zu machen, als wir das bis jetzt machen. Und da kommen immer wieder neue mathematische Gruppen, die sagen, wir versuchen das. Und wir haben jetzt auf unserer Webseite die besten Lösungen für eine ganze Klasse von Missionen publiziert. Und wir fragen kontinuierlich die wissenschaftliche Gemeinschaft, wer eine bessere Lösung findet, schickt sie uns. Und dann publizieren wir euch als Record Holder.
Ist das jetzt immer noch dieselbe Aufgabe? Und kommen dafür immer noch weitere Lösungen?
Jedes Jahr gibt es eine neue Competition, die immer von dem Gewinner der letzten Competition ausgetragen wird, so wie der America's Cup. Die erste Competition hat GPL gewonnen. Die zweite Competition...
Also die allererste wurde hier gestartet?
Ja, haben wir gestartet. Und der Sieger war GPL, eine tolle Gruppe.
Also Propulsion Laboratories der NASA.
Und dann der nächste Sieger war eine italienische Uni von Turin, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Dann hat CNES das nächste Jahr gewonnen. CNES ist die französische Raumfahrtbehörde. Und das letzte Jahr hat eine russische Uni gewonnen. Das letzte Jahr hat eine russische Uni gewonnen. Na, das vorletzte Jahr hat eine russische Uni gewonnen. Und die haben jetzt den Wettbewerb dieses Jahr veranstaltet. Und dieses Jahr hat wer gewonnen? Die Chinesen sind dieses Mal zweiter geworden. Die waren immer unterferner liefen und dieses Mal sind sie zweiter geworden. Und ich glaube, gewonnen hat dieses Jahr... Nochmal GPL. Das zweite Mal GPL.
Also, als ihr das erste Mal gewonnen habt, darf man den Pokal behalten.
Ja, wir haben einen Pokal von einem spanischen Artisten, der weitergereicht wird.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen, dass das immer eine besondere Herausforderung ist. Sowas gibt es ja auch im Softwarebereich auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise. Und es macht natürlich, einerseits natürlich Spaß, aber es bringt natürlich dann auch wirklich mal Ergebnisse, ohne dass man jetzt eben so einen konkreten Auftrag für irgendetwas braucht. Und daraus kann man dann wahrscheinlich auch eine Menge gewinnen, weil ich vermute mal, die Ergebnisse, also auch die Wegfindung sozusagen muss ja dann dokumentiert werden.
Das ist alles voll publiziert, ja.
Und hat das schon, ich meine, das könnte ich mir vorstellen, könnte ja auch wirklich Auswirkungen auf die Missionsplanung, die aktuelle auch haben, dass man sagt, oh, hier interessanter Ansatz und so. Weil das bringt ja eine Menge. Ich meine, wenn man nur, gut, Impact, ist es jetzt immer dieses Impact-Beispiel?
Nein, nein, nein, jedes Jahr der Sieger wählt ein anderes Problem, das seines Erachtens sehr kompliziert ist. Also letztes Jahr.
Aber es hat immer was mit Flugbahnen zu tun?
Es hat immer was mit Flugbahnen zu tun. Es heißt G-Doc Global Trajectory Optimization Competition.
Ja, aber das hat ja riesige Auswirkungen. Ich meine, wir hatten ja hier wieder mal ein kleiner Verweis auf eine andere Sendung. Die zweite Ausgabe von Raumzeit hat sich konkret eben mit Missionsplanung beschäftigt. Max Landgraf da von ESOC hat da erzählt und da wurde ja auch schnell deutlich, dass viel davon abhängt, also der Zeitverlauf und damit natürlich auch immer die Kosten und im Falle von maximaler Impact die Effizienz, also wie sehr kann man sozusagen das eingesetzte Geld und die eingesetzte Zeit, das hängt ja auch eng miteinander zusammen, dann auch effektiv nutzbar machen.
Ja, so ist es. Es ist ganz wesentlich, dass man eine effiziente Bahn findet. Und die Konzepte, die wir da entwickeln, sind hauptsächlich interessant für Early Mission Planning. Phasen A von Missionen, wo man noch nicht genau weiß, wo man noch einen, wo man geschwind abschätzen muss, können wir unter Umständen dort und dort hingehen, wie viel Treibstoff müssen wir mitnehmen, falls wir diese Bahn wählen und so weiter. Wie können wir das geschwind optimisieren? Weil die erste, der first guess, unter Umständen hat etliche hundert Kilogramm mehr Treibstoff als der optimale. Man will natürlich relativ schnell wissen, wie viel Treibstoff man für die optimale Bahn dorthin braucht. Das will man für verschiedenste Konzepte im frühen Stadium von Missionen schnell abschätzen können. Deswegen sind da effiziente Methoden, um große Lösungsräume schnell abzutesten wichtig. Wenn es dann darum geht, eine Bahn, die man schon ungefähr optimiert hat, dann wirklich zu pflegen, dann sind andere Lösungsansätze notwendig. Da geht es darum, wann man welchen Trust am Spacecraft einschaltet. Da kommen andere Constraints dazu. Aber das ist dann das Fine-Tuning für die wirkliche Mission.
Wäre es eigentlich auch interessant, sich auch schon gelaufene Missionen anzuschauen, die durchgelaufen sind, und dass man sich anschaut, wie hätte man das auch anders machen können, um diese Konzepte ganz konkret zu manifestieren?
Wenn man sich die Beispiele auf der Webseite der Gruppe anschaut, dann sieht man, dass zum Beispiel die Casinemission, die Voyager-Missions immer wieder als Benchmarks herangnommen werden. Das ist das, was damals möglich war. Mit meiner Art und Weise würden wir um so viel weniger Treibstoff brauchen. Also man verwendet schon alte, richtige, gängige Missionen, weil man das auch konkret quantifizieren kann, wie viel weiter weg Voyager jetzt schon wäre.
Der ist nur wirklich weit gekommen. Casini ist auch ein anderes Beispiel für eine Mission, die dann auch wirklich verdammt weit draußen ist. Energiegewinnung aus dem Vakuum. Inwiefern ist denn Energiegewinnung bei euch grundsätzlich ein Thema?
Energiegewinnung ist ein großes Thema im Weltraum an und für sich. Weil im Weltraum haben wir ganz andere Vorgaben als hier auf der Erde, wo wir ja weiterhin fossile Energieträger verbrennen. Und die haben wir im Weltraum nicht zur Verfügung. Das heißt, die Energie, die wir brauchen, müssen wir mit dem generieren, was im Weltraum zur Verfügung steht. Und das ist hauptsächlich Solarenergie. Das heißt, über lange Zeit.
Was heißt hauptsächlich? Gibt es sonst noch irgendwas?
Ja, zum Beispiel, wenn man zu weit weg von der Sonne ist, dann braucht man diese Nuklearbatterien, die zum Beispiel die Sonden Voyager, Pioneer, Cassini, Huygens mit Energie versorgt haben. Wenn man zu weit weg von der Sonne ist. Und die Atomoberte des Weltraums? Das sind Konzepte, die darauf bestehen, dass manche Materialien zerfallen aufgrund ihrer internen Komposition. Und dieser radioaktive Zerfall setzt Wärme frei. Und diese Wärme braucht man, um Teile des Satelliten über einer gewissen Temperatur zu halten. Typischerweise Batterien sind etwas temperatursensibel. Und diese Wärme kann man auch dazu verwenden, elektrischen Strom zu generieren. Mit Photovoltaic Sebeck. Nicht Photovoltaic, mit dem Sebeck- oder Peltier-Effekt. Und das wird verwendet, um zum Beispiel die Pioneer-Sonden und die Voyager-Sonden, die mittlerweile so weit weg sind von der Sonne, dass sie unmöglich von der Sonne genügend Energie bekommen könnten, um ihre Sensoren zu betreiben und um Daten zurückzusenden, die brauchen diese.
Die Voyager-Sonden sind ja jetzt auch schon voll aus unserem Sonnensystem herausgetreten. Also je nachdem, wo man Anfang und Ende dann so definieren möchte. Aber zumindest so weit weg, dass da schon ganz kalt ist.
Ja, selbst bei der Jupiter-Entfernung hat man nur mal ein paar Prozent von dem, was man in der Erde zur Verfügung hat. Ich glaube, mein Kollege Gerhard Schwem hat das sicherlich erwähnt, dass die Solarpanele der Rosetta-Mission, die bis zum Jupiter-Orbit rausgeht, extrem groß und extrem effizient speziell entwickelt werden. Nur damit ist man genügend Energie, soweit von der Sonne noch generiert, um den Hibernation-Modus genügend Energie für diesen zu haben. Im Weltraum sind die Energiekonditionen ganz anders. Und ganz anders sind nicht nur woher die Energie kommt, hauptsächlich Sonnenenergie, also für alle ESA-Missionen, die wir jetzt haben, ist das die Energie der Sonne mit Photovoltaik, wo über Jahrzehnte der Weltraum der Markt für Photovoltaikanlagen war. Und der Weltraum hat da die Technologie vorwärts gedreht. Aber auch, wie man die Energie benutzt, die Energieeffizienz unserer Systeme ist wahrscheinlich einer der effizienten, wenn man einen energieeffizienten Ingenieur sucht, dann sollte man am besten zu einem Weltraumtechniker gehen.
Da spielt das wirklich eine große Rolle.
Jedes Milliwatt, das man spart, spielt eine große Rolle, weil das einen Impact hat über die Masse, die man braucht, über die Größe der Batterie, über die Größe der Solarpanele. Wenn man schaut, wie unsere Rover zum Beispiel für ExoMars konzipiert sind, dann streiten sich der Wissenschaftler um jedes Milliwatt, das sie haben können vom System. Es geht wirklich darum, höchst hocheffiziente, energieeffiziente Systeme zu bauen. Und jede Ineffizienz muss man im Weltraum ja auch wieder loswerden. Das heißt, wenn ein System ineffizient wird, dann wird es warm und die Wärme muss man wieder loswerden. Das heißt, wir nützen die Wärme der Ineffizienz, dort wo wir es brauchen. Und oft müssen wir für ein System konzipieren, dass in thermischen Umgebungen operieren muss, dass von minus 50, 60, 70 Grad bis plus 30, 40, 50 Grad. Das heißt, bei plus 30, 40, 50 Grad muss man unter Umständen Wärme, die man generiert, weil das System nicht effizient genug ist, hat das wieder einen Einfluss, weil man Radiatoren braucht, um die Wärme loszuwerden. Und Radiatoren heißt, man braucht zusätzlich Masse, Platz und so weiter. Energieeffizienz ist ein Riesenthema im Weltraum.
Inwiefern spielt das bei euch konkret eine Rolle?
Wir haben etliche Studien bezüglich Energiegewinnung im Weltraum gemacht. Wenn man sich anschaut, wie die Entwicklung der Energiegewinnung im Weltraum abgelaufen ist, dann haben die ersten Photovoltaikzellen Milliwatts zusätzlich zu On-Board-Batteries beigetragen. Dann sind sie immer besser geworden. Mittlerweile sind Batteries nur mehr dazu da, wenn man in einer Eclipse ist.
Als Überbrückungs-
und Backup-Maßnahme. Aber nicht mehr wie am Anfang als Hauptenergie-Träger, weil die Satelliten sowieso nur ein paar Tage, ein paar Wochen im Orbit waren. Aber die Systeme sind immer effizienter geworden. Seit den späten 60er Jahren gibt es die Idee, im Weltraum könnte man eigentlich mehr Energie generieren über Photovoltaikanlagen, als man im Weltraum braucht, könnte man das dann nicht an die Erde zurückliefern. Das Konzept an und für sich ist schon interessant, das mal durchzuspielen. Weil im Weltraum scheint die Sonne 24 Stunden am Tag. Das heißt, man kann keine Tag-Nacht-Zyklen, wenn man im richtigen Orbit ist.
Keine Wolken?
Man hat keine Wolken, keine Wetterschwankungen. Aber man hat natürlich den Nachteil, dass man die Energie kabellos übertragen muss, dorthin, wo man es wirklich braucht. Aber da gibt es auch interessante Lösungsansätze, wie man Energie kabellos übertragen kann. Da gibt es zum Beispiel mit Lasers, zum Beispiel mit Mikrowellen. Und zwar gibt es da seit den 60er Jahren Laborversuche. Ende der 70er Jahren hat GPL einen Landmark-Experiment gemacht, wo sie 20 Kilowatt über ca. 2 Kilometer übertragen, mit einer relativ hohen Effizienz, schon damals so 50-60%, was natürlich noch nicht genug ist. Aber es hat demonstriert, dass man in große Mengen eine Energie über relativ weite Distanzen effektiv übertragen kann. Und wenn man sagt, das sind die ersten Technologischritte, das kann man sicher noch optimieren, das kann man sicher noch besser machen, dann kann man schon zu dem Schluss kommen, naja, eigentlich...
Könnte das Kraftwerk der Zukunft im Orbit sein?
Wie vergleicht sich ein Kraftwerk, ein Solarkraftwerk im Orbit mit großflächigen Solarkraftwerken auf der Erde, zum Beispiel in der Sahara? Das Dessert-Tech-Projekt ist ja ein fantastisches, sehr interessantes Projekt, das sich damit beschäftigt. Die Sahara ist auch nicht so weit entfernt. Dort scheint die Sonne intensiver, länger. Könnte man nicht dort großflächig Solarkraftwerke installieren und dann den Strom über etliche 1000 Kilometer mit teilweise Unterseekabeln, Hochspannungsleitungen nach Europa transportieren? Wenn man sich das anschaut, haben die auch gewisse Probleme, zum Beispiel Tag-Nacht-Zyklen. Wir verbrauchen Energie nicht nur, wenn die Sonne scheint, sondern auch, wenn die Sonne nicht scheint. Das heißt, wenn wir am Abend von der Arbeit heimkommen und den Fernseher, Mikrowelle und den Kochherd auftreten, dann ist da ein gewisser Energieverbrauch nach Sonnenuntergang. Man kann da natürlich ein bisschen spielen, wo die Solarkraftwerke stationiert sind und mit einer Lastenverteilung innerhalb von einem großflächigeren Netz. Aber das ist schon interessant zu schauen, wenn man da Solarkraftwerke im Weltraum hat, die 24 Stunden am Tag Energie liefern, wo man sehr schnell entscheiden kann, wo man sie nun hinliefert. Das heißt, man kann die terrestrischen Infrastrukturen für die Verteilung optimieren. Da braucht man keine langen Leitungen, die relativ viel Land brauchen, unter Umständen Untersee-Kabeln. Sondern die könnte man, wie die Japaner das andenken, über einer Meeresfläche platzieren, in der Nähe von Verbraucherzentren. Dann kommt man zu Konzepten, wo man sagt, naja, das ist noch nicht wirklich reif für ein industrielles Projekt. Weil da gibt es noch zu viele Themen, die technologisch weiterentwickelt würden. Aber andererseits ist es zu interessant für eines der Probleme, die wir sowieso haben. Das heißt, unser Energiesystem in ein nachhaltigeres System umzuwandeln. Das heißt, da gibt es durchaus gute Gründe zu sagen, das sollte man schon weiter anschauen. Vielleicht in einem Zeitraum 2020, 2025, dass man die Technologien so weit hat, dass man sagt, kann das eine wirkliche, vielleicht nicht alternative sein, aber kann das ein zusätzliches Putzelstein sein in unserem Energiemix, der unter Umständen terrestrische Solarkraftwerke insofern unterstützt, dass sie dann weniger lokalen Energiespeicher brauchen.
Wie machen wir das jetzt vorstellen? Werden das jetzt so geostationäre Dinge, die dann auch für dich konstant immer auf einen Punkt runterlasern?
Laser ist eine Möglichkeit, wobei man laser, da verliert man noch relativ viel Energie in der Energieumwandlung von elektrischer Energie zu laser und dann laser zu elektrischer Energie. Da gibt es noch viel Raum, um das zu optimieren.
Und bei den Mikrowellen ist das anders?
Das ist ein bisschen besser schon. Da gibt es vor allem an der Universität Kobe in Japan seit Jahren Forschungen, wie man das optimiert. Und die haben da Effizienzen, die für die Mikrowellenübertragung an und für sich weit über 80 Prozent schon sind. Und das wird dann schon interessant. Und die haben eine der Core Features von dieser Mikrowellenübertragung. Haben sie erst vor zwei Jahren in Hawaii getestet, wo sie von einem Berggipfel auf einen anderen Berggipfel mit dieser Technologie Energie übertragen haben. Das war natürlich in sehr geringen Energiedichten. Und vor allem hat man da das System getestet und so weiter. Wir haben da auch mit den Japanern ein interessantes Experiment gemacht, das heißt Furoshiki-Kassen, wo wir so ein Retro-Directive-Antennasystem heißen. Das ist ein Antennensystem, wo die Antennenelemente nicht physisch aneinanderhängen, sondern an verschiedenen flexiblen Standpunkten auf einer Plattform sind oder auf einem Netz hängen. In unserem Fall war das ein aufgespanntes Netz. Wir haben geschaut, ob wir von der Erde diese verschiedenen Antennenelemente so steuern können, dass sie ihre Phasen so koordinieren, dass sie genau auf den Punkt zurückbeamen, von dem dieses Steuersignal gekommen ist. Das hat wunderbar funktioniert. Das war doch über 140 Kilometer Distanz vom Weltraum in die Erde. Das ist natürlich nur über ein paar Minuten gegangen, weil das einer dieser Sounding-Rockets war. Aber mit diesen kleinen Schritten versuchen wir, das generelle Konzept Energie aus dem Weltraum Schritt für Schritt ein bisschen zur Reife zu bringen, sodass es dann als wirkliche Alternative, auch vielleicht in 2020, 2025, vielleicht 2030, vielleicht schon früher, es kommt darauf an, wie schnell das geht, als Alternative möglich ist für großflächigere Energiegewinnung aus dem Weltraum. Das ist nicht für jetzt, aber das ist durchaus etwas, wo man sagt, das sollte man sich schon ein bisschen genauer angucken.
Jetzt geht es ja schon über die eigentliche Raumfahrt hinaus. Hier geht es ja um einen ganz neuen Nutzungsbereich der Raumfahrt und gar nicht mehr so, wie können wir die Raumfahrt als solche verbessern oder optimieren, sondern was sind noch mal im ganz anderen Bereich, neben denen, die wir bisher besprochen haben? Was sind denn noch so... Es gibt ja auch so ein paar bekannte Probleme, wo derzeit die Raumfahrt insgesamt ein Problem hat, wie zum Beispiel Weltraum, Schrott. Das hatten wir ja hier auch schon mal ausführlich diskutiert bei Raumzeit. Ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht, ich glaube auch Skabel 7. Dass halt am Anfang der Raumfahrt nicht so richtig bedacht wurde. Dass das ja alles auch irgendwann mal... Dass es vielleicht nicht alles wieder runterkommt, sondern dann ewig kreist und dann auf einmal gar kein Platz mehr ist. Ist das für euch auch ein Thema?
Ja, das ist sogar ein sehr interessantes Thema. Vor zwei Jahren haben wir da einen Call for Ideas für Unis gestartet. Das ist eines dieser Themen, wo es noch viel Raum für kreative, wissenschaftliche Ideen gibt, wie man diesem Problem jetzt am besten behandelt. Da gibt es eine ganze Menge von Ansätzen. Die eher klassischen Ansätze sind Roboteransätze, wo man sagt, man hat da einen Roboterarm, der unter Umständen das Spacecraft einfängt und dann gemeinsam deobitet, sodass es in Atmosphäre verglüht. Der erste Schritt, und das ist der Schritt, den die ESA schon einiger Zeit macht, ist natürlich versuchen, so weit es möglich ist, zusätzlichen Weltraumschrott zu vermeiden. Das ist etwas, was in allen unseren Programmen implementiert ist. Aber es scheint so, als ob, selbst wenn man keinen zusätzlichen Schrott mehr produziert, über lange Zeit räumen, das heißt wir sprechen da über 20, 50, 20, 100, dass der existierende Schrott unter Umständen kollidiert, neuen Schrott generiert und dass es dann gewisse Orbits gibt, die nicht mehr so sicher wären, wie sie heute sind. Nicht, dass man keinen Platz mehr dort hätte, aber die Einschlagswahrheit steigt so hoch, dass man sagt, da sollte man den Orbit vermeiden. Und diese Situation soll man vermeiden, weil das ist wie mit allen Dingen, wir sollten den Weltraum unserer nächsten Generation so übergeben, wie wir ihn vorzufinden wünschen. Das ist so wie mit den Clothes, das sollte man auch so hinterlassen.
Was kam da jetzt für Ideen aus der Uni heraus?
Wir haben die Uni speziell gefragt, wir wollen nicht irgendeine Idee, die jetzt schon existiert, weiterverfolgen und besser machen, sondern schaut, was da noch für alternative Ansätze gibt. Wir haben da drei Ansätze weiterverfolgt. Einer war, der für sich ganz lustig ist, und zwar funktioniert er nur in erdnahen Orbits, wo man sagt, man bringt einen Schaum, man sprüht einen schaum, einen klebrigen Schaum, einen Weltraumschrott, und in dem der Schaum aufgeht, erhöht er den Natural Atmospheric Drag.
Ach so, er vergrößert sozusagen seine Bremsfläche.
Die Bremsfläche.
Das ist immer schwierig mit dem Englisch. Ich kann das gut nachvollziehen, auch wenn man so in Computerkreisen einen Stoch hat, dann ist immer alles so überladen, aber gerade hier am S-Tag, hier spricht jeder Englisch, beziehungsweise hier werden alle möglichen Sprachen gesprochen, und Englisch ist so der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner und natürlich auch so die Quelle aller Begriffe. Das muss schwierig sein, mal so eben auf Deutsch umzuschalten. Na gut, aber bleiben wir dabei. Man lässt die Dinger sozusagen an, dann werden sie irgendwie dicker, also kriegen sie so eine Flockung.
Und dann bremst es halt mehr. Und dann ist es natürlich keine kontrollierte Re-Entry, sondern es ist ein Un-Controll-Entry. Es fällt mit einem Sort in einem Spiral Trajectory. Aber das ist etwas, was interessant ist, weil man muss nicht docken. Man muss manche dieser Space Debris, die rotieren mit einer gewissen Geschwindigkeit. Und es ist dann schwierig, die einzufangen, ohne dass man das eigentliche Spacecraft unter Umständen in Gefahr bringt. Das ist auch nicht so einfach. Robotisch ist es nicht so einfach. Und wenn man nur etwas sprüht, das sicher klebt und dann größer wird, das könnte für manche Debris schon ganz interessant sein. Also das ist eines der Konzepte, die wir uns angeschaut haben. Ein zweites ist mit Solar Sails. Und zwar gibt es an der Universität Zary ein sehr interessantes Projekt, Solar Sails aufzuspannen. Sonnensegel aufzuspannen. Und wir haben uns angeschaut, ob man unter Umständen mit so kleinen Sonnensegeln... Was heißt das?
Das ist so eine Fläche, wo dann der Sonnenwind eingefangen wird...
.der Sonnenwind eingefangen wird, richtig, ja. Und mit dem Druck des Sonnenwinds kann man die Bahn verändern.
Das heißt, man schießt dann mit so einer Gummipistole sozusagen so ein Segel an das Objekt an.
So ähnlich kann man sich das vorstellen. Wir haben uns auch angeschaut, ob man unter Umständen elektrodynamische Tethers verwenden kann, um zusätzlich das Magnetfeld der Erde dazu verwenden, um die Geschwindigkeit dieses Weltraummülls abzubremsen. Wobei das weniger interessant ausschaut nach den ersten Analysen, die wir gerade publiziert haben.
Das ist ein interessantes Thema.
Das dritte Konzept kommt von einem ganz innovativen Team auf der Universität in Madrid. Und zwar haben die gesagt, eines der Probleme ist wirklich, dass man mit diesem Debris undockt. Wie kann man Impuls übertragen, ohne dass man dockt? Und zwar in einer kontrollierten Art und Weise, nicht so wie der Foam, der eher unkontrolliert wäre. Und ihm gesagt, wir könnten ja das gleiche Prinzip verwenden, das wir verwenden für Electric Propulsion System, also Ionen-Triebwerke. Und wir könnten Ionen auf diesen Weltraumshot schießen. Und wenn man genügend davon über eine längere Zeit schießt, dann übertragen zwar jedes Ion einzeln nur einen geringen Impuls, aber über die Dauer könnte das genug sein, um die Bahn zu ändern. Und es scheint so zu sein...
Aus welchem Abstand müsste man das machen?
Wir haben da verschiedene Szenarien durchgespielt, aber es ist durchaus realistisch, bis auf 5, 10, 20 Meter an so einem... Also sehr nah. Das ist schon zahlhaft. Aber wenn man docken muss, dann muss man... Und wir haben da simuliert, man kann da sogar sehr große, massive Upper Stages, also die letzten Stufen von Raketen, kann man damit von Orbits 1000 Kilometer und abwärts deorbeten. Also da sind gerade zwei Papers rausgekommen, wo wir hoffen, dass die internationale Wissenschaftlergemeinde die zerpflückt und schaut, was da jetzt unter Umständen noch zu machen ist, was wir vielleicht unter Umständen, wenn wir in gewissen Sachen zu optimistisch oder nicht optimistisch genug, wir wissen, dass die CNES, eine Forschergruppe in Japan und eine Forschergruppe in Frankreich, so eine ähnliche Idee unabhängig von uns schon einmal durchgespielt haben.
Was ist denn so ein Ionen-Gebläse im Weltraum, mit dem man einfach alles wegboostet, so ein Stoppsauger, so ein Ungedrehter?
Wegboosten ist vielleicht ein bisschen optimistisch, aber ja, mit Ionen Energie übertragen, das ist so viel.
Genau, aber es ist ja gar nicht so viel nötig, weil die Teile ja gerade in den niedrigen Orbits ohnehin irgendwann fallen. Es geht ja nur darum, diesen Zeitraum merklich zu verkürzen, dass es nicht 100 Jahre dauert, sondern vielleicht nur 10. Und dann verbessert sich ja die Situation dann auch entsprechend. Und da kann man dann auch abwägen. Nach dem Motto, so und so viel Energie können wir da jetzt wirklich realistisch hinbringen. Um das Ding in einem Jahr unterzukriegen, müsste man halt so viel Energie aufwenden. Das ist vielleicht zu viel, aber mit dem Aufwand dauert es dann nur noch zehn Jahre. Und dann ist das Ganze dann halt auch halbwegs wirtschaftlich so, denke ich mir.
Ja, und es gibt Kollegen in der ESOC in Darmstadt, die sind da wirklich spezialisiert, auch welchen Weltraumschrott, also welches Teil man da wann am besten deorbitet, um dieses Kessler-Syndrom, das exponentiell weiteren Schrott generiert, einzudämmen. Und Holger Krag, ich glaube, ich hab's ja eh schon mal geplaudert. Er hat da ganz tolle modelle, mathematische Modelle entwickelt, um da festzustellen, wie viele Objekte man pro Jahr deorbiten müsste. Und das sind gar nicht so viele, das ist eine Handvoll.
Holger Krag war ja auch der Gesprächspartner in dem schon erwähnten Raumzeit-Podcast Nummer 7. Und diesen Aspekt der Verwendung von Robotik, also das Aufpiksen quasi und Wegführen von größeren Objekten, das kam zur Sprache hier mit Klaus Landzettel in Ausgabe Nummer 14, wo es um Wesentlichen um Robotik in der Raumfahrt ging. Und das war dann halt so eine mögliche Anwendung. Was für große, schwere Objekte natürlich dann wiederum ein durchaus denkbarer Weg ist, wo man jetzt nicht, glaube ich, mit Ionen totpusten würde.
Na, es ist auch mit Ionen möglich, Upper Stages zu die Orbit.
Es ging ja auch, sagen wir mal, um Objekte im geostationären Bereich, in die Parkpositionen gefahren, et cetera. Vorhin im Gespräch fiel nochmal so ein anderer Begriff, den ich jetzt gar nicht zuordnen kann, Curiosity Cloning.
Curiosity Cloning ist ein ganz interessantes Projekt gewesen. Wie klont man denn Neugier? Wir wissen es nicht wirklich genau, aber es hat ein paar interessante Resultate gegeben vor kurzem, wo man herausgefunden hat, dass man mit Brain Machine Interfaces, BMI, wo man die Hirnströme analysiert, kann man quasi rausfinden oder detektieren, wann jemand von etwas überrascht ist. Und dieser Überraschungseffekt ist natürlich wissenschaftlich gesehen oft verbunden mit etwas, was man nicht gerechnet hat.
So ein Aha-Effekt.
So ein Aha, oder komisch. Und das ist oft der Ursprung von der Entdeckung von Sachen, die man gar nicht gesucht hat. Und die Idee, die wir der Arien verfolgt haben, war die folgende. Wenn man den Aha-Effekt, diesen Überraschungseffekt, messen kann mit Gehirnströmen, dann könnte man unter Umständen auch messen, ob ein Wissenschaftler von etwas interessiert ist, an etwas interessiert ist, das er sieht. Und zwar, indem er darauf schaut oder indem das gewisse Hirnströme auslöst. Und da war vor etlichen Jahren einer der letzten Apollo-Astronauten da in der Esthek und hat einen Vortrag gegeben und eines der Themen in der Diskussion war damals der einzige Wissenschaftler am Mond, hat offensichtlich die Steine, die er mitgenommen hat. Die Steine, die der mitgenommen hat, waren wesentlich aufschlussreicher als die Steine der meisten anderen Apollo-Astronauten, die eher einen Background gehabt haben als Fighter-Pilots. Einfach weil er mit seinem wissenschaftlichen Hintergrund, mit seinem geologen Hintergrund, gedacht hat, das sieht aber interessant aus. Das sieht interessant aus. Natürlich kann man nicht überall Menschen hinschicken. Das wissen wir ganz genau. Andererseits wäre es doch interessant, wenn wir einen Roboter hinschicken könnten, der ähnlich reagieren könnte wie ein Geologe, der spezialisiert ist auf gewisse Gesteinsformen und so weiter. Und wo wir dem Roboter die verschiedensten Curiosity Models von wirklichen Wissenschaftlern aufspielen könnten. Und das ist natürlich die Endvision dieser Curiosity Cloning. Der erste Schritt war, können wir wirklich wissenschaftliche Curiosity detektieren. Und wenn man das dann detektieren kann, dann kann man es auch charakterisieren. Und wenn man es charakterisieren kann, kann man es unter Umständen in Algorithmen einbauen. Und diese Algorithmen könnte man dann verwenden und zu sagen, wir filtern alle möglichen Bilder, die der Roboter jetzt vor sich will, kommt nach verschiedensten Kriterien. Und eines der Kriterien könnte sein, ob die Curiosity von diesen und diesen Scientisten ausschlagen werde. Aber das ist ein bisschen Zukunftsmusik, aber das veranschaulicht ein bisschen die Art und Weise, wie wir an Dinge herangehen mit ersten Schritten und schauen, ist das interessant und umständlich.
Genau, sich einfach nicht mal blockieren mit irgendwelcher Realität, sondern das einfach mal die Realität sein lassen.
Die Realität in dem Fall war, dass ein Wissenschaftler gezeigt hat, dass man den Überraschungseffekt, dass man Überraschung messen kann.
Man meinte, die Realität im Sinne, die einen immer davon abhält und einem sagt, das wird ja eh nicht funktionieren.
Ja, natürlich. Das ist in gewisser Weise meine Rolle in der Gruppe, die eine gute Balance zu finden zwischen einem Hausverstand approachen und sagen, naja, das ist jetzt zu unrealistisch, das wird nicht funktionieren. Und auf der anderen Seite die Wissenschaftler doch zu ermutigen auch... .out of the box zu denken und sich durchaus in Gebiete vorzuwagen, wo sie ihre natural comfort zone ein bisschen verlassen. Da muss ich jetzt meine Grundannahmen nochmal überdenken und schauen, wie kann man das unter Umständen anders angehen. Das ist kein linearer Prozess, das funktioniert dann nicht jeden Tag gleich. Wir haben Perioden, wo wir sehr erfolgreich sind, sehr kreativ, und andere Perioden, wo sie ja...
Mal wächst die Wurzel und mal wächst die Wurzel nicht, um mal wieder den Beginn des Gesprächs hier ein bisschen aufzunehmen. Ja, das bringt uns langsam zum Ende, aber wenn wir so viel über Talentsuche auf der einen Seite und auch Ideensuche auf der anderen Seite kommt, fällt mir natürlich unweigerlich das omnipräsente Internet auf. Inwiefern spielt denn das Netz bei euch eine Rolle, oder was habt ihr noch für andere Modelle, um überhaupt diese Talent- und Ideensuche noch weiter auszudehnen, als jetzt nur über Universitäten und den eigenen Kosmos hinaus. Das ist ja sicherlich auch ein Thema, oder?
Grundsätzlich beschäftigen wir, wie es mittlerweile klar ist, mit Fragestellungen, wo wir daran interessiert sind, dass wir Feedback bekommen, wissenschaftlichen Feedback, Peer Review. Also wir publizieren alles, wir stellen alles auf unsere Webseite und wir sind über jede Anregung und Feedback dankbar und daran sehr interessiert. Wir haben auch ein paar Projekte erst vor kurzem gehabt, die ein bisschen weitergehen in die Richtung scientific crowdsourcing. Das Beispiel war wieder Trajectories, wo wir schon... Wir haben da ein Spiel online gestellt, das ist thespacegame.org, wo jeder mit realistischen physikalischen Modellen Bahnen entwerfen kann. Und das System berechnet dann, wie effizient die Bahn ist. Also da geht es hauptsächlich um, welche Flybys man wann einsetzt, um eben Schwung zu holen, also an Planeten, an anderen Körpern vorbei und dann die Anziehung des Objektes auszulassen. Während der letzten Space Week International, die immer im Oktober ist, haben wir das in einer Woche gelauncht. Da waren Tausende von Spielern, die ihre, die mit Trial and Error wirklich sehr schnell Lösungen gefunden haben für ein Problem, wo wir ungefähr gewusst haben, was das optimale ist. Was uns daran interessiert ist, wie die menschliche Intuition sehr schnell optimale Lösungen findet. Und wir würden gern dieses Spiel quasi verwenden, um die Herangehensweise der Spieler zu analysieren und daraus Schlüsse zu ziehen, wie wir unsere Algorithmen verbessern können, die natürlich auch ähnliche Herangehensweisen ausprobieren müssen. Das Scientific Crowdsourcing ist ein Hot Topic. Das ist ein erster Ansatz in diese Richtung. Du hast das Internet erwähnt. Viele unserer Scientific Tools werden als Open Source Tools publiziert und wir sind dankbar über jeden Beitrag, der von...
Was für Tools sind das also?
Tools für Global Optimization, Parallelization of Code. Das sind unsere zwei Hauptprojekte, die wir auf Source 4 schauen.
Berechnungsalgorithmen?
Ja, das sind so Art Algorithmen, da kann man auch eigene Algorithmen entwickeln, die man in diesem Parallelizer implementieren kann. Und wir haben gerade nach der Google Summer of Code Initiative eine ähnliche Initiative für die ESA gestartet. Das ist noch ein Pilotprojekt, wo wir Studenten dazu animieren, an Weltraumprojekten beizutragen, mit programmieren für drei Monate. Wo es ein kleines Stibendium gibt.
ESA Summer of Code in Space. In Space no one can hear you code.
Ja, das läuft grad.
Da kann man sich bewerben.
Für dieses Jahr ist es vorbei, weil der Summer ist vorbei. In Hohen haben wir gar keinen Summer gehabt. Der Sommer läuft in dem Fall Anfang August bis Ende Oktober. Das sind ca. 20 Studenten, die da jetzt an Open Source Space Projects mitarbeiten.
Die sich jeweils einzeln beworben haben oder als Gruppe. Wie ist das gelaufen?
Studenten haben sich insgesamt weit über 100 beworben. Wir haben das so ähnlich wie Google gemacht. Wir haben zuerst existierende Open Source Space Projects gefragt, sie sollen ihr Projekt einreichen mit einem Projektumfang, den ein Student während drei Monaten bewältigen kann und der interessant ist.
Also es geht sozusagen ähnlich wie bei Google um die Weiterentwicklung, gegebenenfalls schon existierender Projekte, die sich ohnehin mit Weltraumweiteren Sinne auseinandersetzen oder eben auch der Erzeugung von neuen mit dem entsprechenden Hintergrund. Und da wurden dann die entsprechenden ausgewählt, wenn man sagt, ok, ja, das ist schon mal ein interessantes Projekt, das fördern wir.
Ja, das Hauptziel in diesem Pilotprojekt war mal mehr Studenten zu animieren, im Weltraum, in den Weltraumsektor ein bisschen reinzuriechen und ohne, dass die jetzt großartig nach Holland kommen müssen oder sich bewerben müssen bei einer Weltraumfirma. Sie können da im Sommer ein bisschen reinrechen, wie Weltraumprojekte programmiert werden und dann unter Umständen ein erstes Gefühl bekommen, was speziell ist am Weltraum. Es ist eher ein Nebenprodukt, dass diese Open Source Projects, die existieren, die manche in unserer täglichen Arbeit verwendet werden, auch weiterentwickelt werden. Wenn das Projekt erfolgreich ist und weiterentwickelt wird, kann das dann auch wirklich zur Weiterentwicklung von Projekten beitragen. Aber der Hauptfokus ist, Studenten zu ermöglichen, dass sie ein bisschen in den Weltraum reinriechen. Und zwar auch Studenten, die unter Umständen vorher überhaupt nichts mit dem Weltraum zu tun gehabt haben, weil sie fantastische Programmierer sind. Und für die der Weltraum, ja, das ist ein eigenes Universum. Ich hab nicht das richtige Studium gehabt, um da wirklich was beizutragen.
Aber wie bringt ihr ihr denn sozusagen, ich meine, Software zu schreiben für Weltraum-Anforderungen hat ja sehr viel mehr mit Qualitätssicherung, Ausfallfreiheit etc. zu tun. Wie bringt ihr den Ausgewählten das jetzt konkret näher, wenn die jetzt hier nicht selbst aufschlagen?
Ja, die Software-Projekte, die da ausgewählt werden sind, die meistens sind Projekte, die bei Unis oder in verschiedensten Firmen als Open Source-Projekte schon entwickelt werden, mit ihren Qualitätsstandards, die in dem Projekt sowieso schon drinnen sind. Die werden wir überhaupt nicht ändern. Unser Beitrag sowieso ist diese Projekte so zu öffnen, dass Studenten da beitragen können. Für diese Projekte ist es oft interessant, einen Student zu haben, der ihnen für drei Monate unter Umständen in gewissen Fragestellungen hilft, einen Teil programmiert, den sie dann in ihren Core-Trunk aufnehmen können. Das ändert überhaupt nichts an der Art und Weise, wie diese Projekte normal entwickelt werden.
Haben wir jetzt noch etwas ganz Wichtiges vergessen? Abgesehen davon, wir haben noch einiges Spannendes. Was Spannendes haben wir bestimmt noch vergessen, aber noch etwas ganz Elementares. Was sich jetzt abgezeichnet hat, denke ich, ist ganz klar, das Team, das Advanced Concepts Team, ist so eine Art Zinktank, der versucht, über natürliche Limitierungen hinaus zu denken und Konzepte und Ideen zu liefern, die vielleicht nicht unmittelbar zu greifbaren Anwendungen führen, aber die zumindest auch schon mal Vorlagen liefern für zukünftige oder auch schon existierende Projekte, wo man sagen kann, da ist schon mal etwas soweit vorgedacht worden, dass man sehen kann, dass das vielleicht sogar real applizierbare Folgen hat. Das hat zumindest seinen ersten Lackmustest bestanden. Das ist schon mal etwas, das ist einmal durchdacht worden. Und das ist ja meistens das, was einen davon abhält, sowas überhaupt zu erwägen. Weil man weiß, da muss jetzt erstmal Grundlagenarbeit geleistet werden. Da muss vor allem gegen die bestehenden Grundlagen gegengetestet werden. Und wenn das schon mal getan ist, dann kann man das natürlich ganz anders aufnehmen. Vielleicht, was mich noch interessieren würde, ist, was ist so deine, du bist ja von Anfang an dabei und betreust es im Wesentlichen organisatorisch. Du hast gesagt, die meisten kommen, bleiben zwei oder drei Jahre und gehen dann wieder raus. Welchen Einfluss hat denn die Arbeit in dem Team auf diejenigen, die jetzt Teil dieses Teams waren und es dann wieder verlassen? Du wirst sicherlich auch Feedback später mal gehört haben, wie es ihnen dann wieder ergangen ist. Inwiefern ist es für die Beteiligten? Was für eine Erfahrung machen die damit? Was können die daraus ziehen?
Ich glaube, die beste Art und Weise, zu antworten ist, zu schauen, was die Wissenschaft dann nachher machen und welche Karrieren sie nachher einschlagen. Die meisten bleiben in einem akademischen Umfeld. Die ältesten, die es jetzt schon acht Jahre gibt, die meisten sind Professor, Assistenzprofessoren, Senior Researchers, Senior Lecturers verteilt in ganz Europa. Ein paar sind in Researchzentren der Space-Industrie. Mittlerweile sind sie immer noch in der Forschungsrichtung.
Also nicht alle schlagen jetzt den Weg ein, auch in der Raumfahrt zu bleiben. Vielleicht der Raumfahrt gewogen, aber halt im universitären Forschungsumfeld. Aber manche auch schon.
Es kommen weniger als die Hälfte der Wissenschaftler, die zu uns kommen, von einem Weltraum-Background. Aber weit mehr als die Hälfte, die uns verlassen, bleiben im Weltraum. Die große Mehrheit bleibt dann im Weltraum, in einer akademischen Karriere, wo der Weltraum eine Rolle spielt. Sie nehmen insofern ein Wissen mit in ihre weitere Karriere, die sie sonst nicht bekommen hätten, auch wenn sie zurück in die Biologie gehen, in die Bionik gehen. Sie machen dann ihre weitere Karriere mit einem Wissen, was der Weltraum bedeutet, was dafür Fragestellungen gibt, die sie sonst nicht wirklich bekommen könnten. Ich glaube, sie haben bei uns wahrscheinlich mehr Freiheiten und mehr Spaß, als sie in ihren meisten anderen Karriere-Schritten haben. Es gibt auch für eine Akademiker wenig Möglichkeiten, in relativ jungen Jahren selbst zu bestimmen, was jetzt die Wissenschaftsdirektion für meine nächsten zwei, drei Jahre ist, wo ich meine Schwerpunkte setze und wo nicht der Professor ein bisschen vorgibt, in welche Richtung man jetzt gehen soll.
Und musst du euch jetzt um Nachwuchs Sorgen machen oder klopfen genug Leute an?
Na, es klopfen genug Leute an. Allerdings nicht wirklich geografisch homogen in Europa. Wir haben zum Beispiel relativ wenig Bewerbungen aus Deutschland und den skandinavischen Ländern. Also relativ im Vergleich zur Größe von Deutschland wird man da doch ein bisschen mehr Bewerbungen erwarten. Vielleicht werden wir nicht genug Werbung machen. Dieser Podcast kann durchaus beitragen, das Team in Deutschland auch bekannter zu machen.
Womit sollte man sich bewerben? Wie ist es, wenn man es tut?
Die Kriterien sind publik auf der Webseite. Jeder Posten hat andere, jeder Vacancy Note hat andere Background Kriterien. Aber man soll sich nicht davon abschrecken lassen, dass man zuvor mit dem Weltraum nichts zu tun gehabt hat, weil, wie schon gesagt, die meisten Wissenschaftler kommen nicht aus einem Weltraum Background. Wir haben einen fantastischen deutschen Biologen, der per Zufall unsere Stelle gefunden hat.
Ihr macht schon konkrete Ausschreibungen?
Ja, wir machen konkrete Ausschreibungen.
Es ist nicht so wahllos, dass man sagt, hier haben wir mal wieder einen Geologen, der würde ja vielleicht ganz gut passen. Nein, nein. Jetzt weiß ich auch nicht mehr, was man noch fragen könnte. Also führen wir die Sache doch langsam mal zu Ende. Leopold, vielen Dank für die Ausführung zum Advanced Concepts Team der ESA hier am Estec in Nordwijk bei Leiden in den Niederlanden. Und auch vielen Dank wie immer an die Hörer fürs fleißige bis zum Ende durchhören. Ich hoffe, es war mal wieder interessant und aufschlussreich. Und in zwei Wochen geht es dann auch wieder weiter mit Raumzeit. Bis dahin viel Spaß bei allem, was ihr tut.